hallo leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen youtube video bei laser luca
wir testen uns heute durch die
asiatische küche
mit uns nicht so viel zu tun ich habe
asiatische süßigkeiten bestellt und ich
dachte mir mit wem sonst könnte ich das
schon als normalerweise
das möchte starten ja mit den chips oder
kennst du den die sonne mond und sterne
hier steht das sind im fish chips
ich habe hinten
[Applaus]
fischbecken die bomben collector
abgelassen damit noch skala von 1 bis 10
tagen ein lecker wiederfanden
[Applaus]
321 ja ja sag ich ja auch gewünscht
weißen hauses als nächstes würde ich
sagen brauchen wir mal ein kleines
kaugummi das sind nämlich so kleine
sachen die so aussehen wie center
schocks
das ist dass
wir diese karamell dinger aber das liegt
nicht wert muss
[Musik]
hmm vergessen ich bin den gärten
konsistenz war gut aber eher wie
kaugummi
gramm täglich
wie mit konstanz ist wie mauer amt ich
mag dich so gern karamell gemixt mit
erdnussbutter ich werde nächstes geboren
ich glaube das sind so hotel stick oder
wie diese dinger heißen die sache ist
dann glaube ich keine schokolade beides
fehlt das chocolate sieht ein bisschen
aus wie erlaubt
nur ein goal und aus rhinow trete ich
merke mir auch wirklich gut nicht stark
3217 relativ gleicher ansicht bei den
ganzen sachen
erst dann gott ganz noch spaß als
nächstes machen wir hier das hier
ist kein einziges wort lesen
was heißt dass potatoes
potato
hinzu gästen
das ja immer nur eine lehrstelle wieder
ist eine salzstange nicht verstanden hat
oder für bogen- und gute szene als
astro das ist abgelaufen oh mein gott in
seiner familie weber account 33 15 15
und den schulen haben das ding dann
würde ich eins oder zwei geben
neben essen ins lotte wo sie bitte
ausschließlich für den chips vielleicht
doch nur 15 haben und sie rückgängig
machen ich habe der verpackung
was für sie und eine kleine brötchen
einfach
[Musik]
321 sehen die schmecken wie dieser
koalas werden euch jemand foto an diese
courage mit schokolade meinte ich als
nächste station wir hier riesige
komischen
also dass sie sind auf jeden fall diese
gummibärchen ähnlichen dinge die wir
essen also ich glaube dass das heute
sind weil die konsistenz lässt sich
schon gar nicht mehr an wenn man hier so
dran rum auch guck mal das sind solche
so wird machen die da sind doch
schlangen guck dir das konnte
nein deutschland ihr richtig schmeckt
mir diese gefälschten von der apotheke
kaufen der apotheke gummibärchen habe
aber wenig
charakter eur 321 du sagst gut und gibt
seine fünf dann sechs revidiert auch und
sat 1 was ja irgendwie gar nicht
geschmeckt mannschaft die ich nach hause
du bist immer ein bis zehn minuten noch
die sag ich ganz ehrlich bin seit sechs
jahren auf die
aber irgendwie jetzt nur breite auch
ganz normal als nächstes nehmen wir
solle bade hat recht
wenn die dinge auf jeden fall aus sie
sehen aus wie so leiten skizze
ist nichts drin
das wird die größte wüste und ein
bauleiter
ich dachte man noch eine überraschung
drin
auf gesamt einer
irgendwo hochwasser ist nehmt diese
dinge und wenn du beim zahnarzt hatte
zwischen kommt so was ja nun als
nächstes essen wir zu kopie sondern wir
jetzt nur einen und ich glaube es ist
auch eine art
ein fake buch und ich weiß noch als
erstes rein
ich finde aber die verpackung manchmal
etwas fallen
wie kann man sowas
erinnert sich dass alle kuchen die du im
supermarkt kauft die eingepackt sind
haben diesen geschmack und da drin ist
noch marshmallows drin film was das
manchmal lust und marshmallows der dj
mich erinnert das eins zu eins an die
schoko waffen die wir früher in unserer
schule hatten stimmen die der
hausmeister verkauf hat mit blauer
verpackungen genau es wird in diesem
kleinen kater grossrat
als nächstes haben wir hier strawberry
sachen sieht ein bisschen auf die mauern
und man glaubt es
ist einfach mal
so
blöd nicht sommerfest so sauer das ist
überhaupt nicht sagt nein da kann ich
das jetzt eigentlich sagen dass
verschiedene
weil ich über süß-sauer umtauschen
kommen hier
weiß ich weiß überhaupt nicht süß oder
so gut aber manchmal richtig süß haben
passt ja auch doof ist meist das auch
nicht einfach nicht mehr anders und
321 loslegen
67 das verstehe ich dann noch dunkel
kampf gegen irgendwas muss jetzt richtig
dauer sein als nächstes haben wir hier
so silberne kekse und das sind auch
irgendwas von früchten darauf abgebildet
aber ich glaube es sind wieder sind
wieder ganz normale stoff trockenen
klicks zu sehen wir auch so leiten
sie ein bisschen schwierig test
aber auch ea ist kein zucker da merkt
man nur dass die roma und doch war nicht
dort ist nicht besser menschen der von
außen alles abgeklappert hat ja immer
als brauneberg und an das schöne leckere
wo sie mich verstehen gerade oder yahoo
muss ich sagen alles trocken ich finde
die gehen warum verwenden dazu brauchst
echtem glas milch natürlich eine
laktoseintoleranz
du wirst sagt uhr sind die vegane jetzt
hoffer mit cover mit 3 2 1
ich bin so was ist so das ist eine
süßigkeit weil man fühlt sich nicht so
ungesund wenn man das ist wenn man denkt
ist es ein krieg sei keine schokolade
dran die fast aber das ist natürlich
auch nur butter nach jedem teil was du
isst denkst du darüber nach ob es gesund
ist oder nicht gesund ja dann hast du es
störung kann man darüber nachdenkt was
man gestern habe ich mein erstes mal
gehört regensdorf darüber nach wie es
wäre naiv zu haben falls nichts nützen
das
vorletzte auch die jüngst
wieder so geht's einfach sind genauso
die riechen nach suppe und mein gott oh
mein gott das ist richtig gut bisschen
kids angesagt mehr gewürze anderer
junger
21 zu sehen finde ich auch zehn check
kann einmal weiter mit der nächsten
maschine boy das ist so ein kleines
gelbes ding auf dem boot oder so und der
fängt gegen welche fische und die ist
man
einer
techno telefon
[Musik]
als das damals immer so was suchen meint
eck zu geben
da kommt doch mal wie sonst im
wahn sich durch waren okay
du hast den menschen die so was machen
damit der ball kommt nicht rein einfach
ja und dann direkt essen mache mut zum
anderssein hatte ich das an diese kleine
ruse aber schon die form gesehen schade
aber
wirklich meine freude waren zehn wege
hab ich habe mich richtig gefreut diese
kennen und paprika das ist so fischig
wieder nein das ist total süß
an dieser stelle rennen war dann auch
das heutige video meiner lieben von euch
gefallen das gerne einen daumen hoch
unter dem video aber nicht den kanal und
blickt auf die glocken weitere wie es
nichts verpassen das war ein highlight
sandra gibt schon vergessen die chips
mein highlight war mein gesicht